BRADY FORREST: Hey,
Adam, next slide.
All right, welcome to Ignite.
[APPLAUSE]
We are super happy
to be back here
for the sixth straight
Ignite at Google I/O.
And we've got eight
amazing speakers for today,
and now we're going
to get started.
So Ignite started a decade ago,
and it's on the simple premise
that everybody has a story,
that everybody deserves a chance
to be a rock star.
But when it first
started out, it
was really just about
giving people a chance
to share ideas over beer.
We set up in a bar.
We invited friends over.
And 200 people showed up.
AUDIENCE: Where's the beer?
BRADY FORREST: Ask Google.
And all of the speakers
got five minutes
on stage, 15 seconds
a slide, 20 slides.
And it turns out that's the
perfect amount of time to share
one idea, to share one story.
And it helps new speakers
really distill their thoughts.
Over time, Ignite started
to spread around the world.
It's now in over 300 cities
on all six continents.
And Ignite is changing.
So very recently,
Tim, our first speaker
allowed me to re-acquire Ignite.
And we are now Ignite Talks PBC,
a public benefit corporation
devoted to giving
people a chance
to experience public
speaking for the first time
around the world.
So thank you very much
for having us here.
And now I'd like to welcome up
my friend, the founder and CEO
of O'Reilly Media, Tim O'Reilly.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM O'REILLY: Hey,
thanks, Brady.
So I'm working on
a new event that I
call the Next Economy
Summit about technology
and the future of work.
I've been out there,
talking to smart people
like Hal Varian who said to me
something that stuck with me.
He said, my grandfather wouldn't
recognize what I do as work.
But was he kidding?
The more things change, the
more they stay the same here.
Here's a bunch of
programmers at Pivotal,
and then a Victorian sweatshop.
But actually, something
is really different.
Because the programmers are
not actually the workers.
Low wage employers like
McDonald's and Walmart
are the new sweatshop.
Something different
is happening in tech.
McDonald's has 440,000
employees delivering 68 services
to 68 million monthly
users, Snapchat 300
to do 100 million users.
Why?
Because this is what
the worker looks like.
That's the GitHub repo for
one of the workers at Google,
TensorFlow, does a whole
lot of work for millions
of users with very few people.
The programmers, all of
you who are programmers,
are actually managers.
Every day you're inspecting the
performance of your workers,
giving them instruction
in the form of code,
about how to do a better job.
That's what the
build, measure, learn
cycle is, it's your
management practices.
But there are other
companies where
the programs are the managers.
Think about Uber or Lyft.
There are programs
telling humans what to do.
They're telling them where to
show up, how much to get paid,
and, of course,
organizing ratings.
But the people who've
written the algorithms
are not necessarily doing a
good job by their human workers.
Because Uber ends up paying
people less than minimum wage
in some cities because
they've written the algorithm
to satisfy only user
needs without thinking
about the needs of the workers.
And this seems to
me to be like what
happened in the
early days of search
with companies like Altavista,
here retrieved from 1996.
You know, it was a pretty
shitty search experience.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, and along came Google.
And they figured out that
by tuning the algorithm,
by figuring out lots and
lots of different factors,
they created a better
experience for users.
They could also
figure out how to get
paid with the ad auction.
There's a lot of
work ahead of us
to figure out how to make
these algorithms that
manage humans work
better for the workers
as well as for the users.
I predicted that this would be
the year in which labor issues
became really critical,
competitive advantage
between Uber and Lyft.
And sure enough,
Uber just made a deal
with the Mechanics Union.
Because as my friend
David Rolf of the SEIU who
spoke at last year's
Next Economy Summit said,
"God did not make being an
auto worker a good job."
Right?
It took a lot of work
by a lot of people
to figure out how to make
work good for humans.
And when you look at a
company like Walmart, which
has really crappy jobs for
humans, managed by algorithms,
the scheduling algorithms that
tell people when to show up,
have no affordances for workers.
When you go to a
McDonald's, you might
be assigned what's called
a "clopen," a shift where
you have to close the store and
open it the next morning, maybe
five hours apart.
And the fact that you live
an hour away doesn't matter.
You don't do it, you get fired--
those terrible algorithms
there.
And that's why the algorithms
that Uber and Lyft are
using actually give
people more affordances.
They haven't yet figured out
how to get people paid enough,
but they are giving
people control
over their lives in a way
that the scheduling algorithms
that made the new
sweatshop do not.
But back to Hal, there
are also other kinds
of jobs he wouldn't
recognize as work.
How about all the
people who are creating
content on social media,
on Facebook and YouTube?
Some people are starting to make
a living at it, but not enough.
I lost a slide here.
I had one in here,
but anyway, we'll
just go forward with this.
This is what led
Jack Conte to start
Patreon, which is a
crowdfunding site for artists.
He was a member of a
musical duo, or still is,
called Pomplamoose
with his wife.
They did 17 million views of
one of their videos on YouTube,
and it turned out
to give them $3,500.
He said, there's got
to be a better way.
And so he basically is now
raising millions of dollars.
Brandon Stanton, Humans
of New York, this guy
has raised millions of
dollars for charity.
But he gets his living
from doing speaking gigs,
amazing social media genius.
So all of this is
a way of saying
we have to think in the same
way that Norman Mailer asked
the question, why
are we in Vietnam
and gave a poem
about American macho,
we have to ask
ourselves, why are we
seeing this political uprising
about income inequality?
And we have a role
in this, because it's
time to build technology and
companies as if people matter.
And because we are actually
not just serving users.
We are building systems of work.
We have to think hard
about the future of work.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Thank you, Tim.
And thanks again for
the support with Ignite.
Now we're going straight
to the future with robots.
Please welcome up the
executive director of Long Now
and the star of
"Battlebots," Zander Rose.
[APPLAUSE]
ZANDER ROSE: Thank you.
Yeah, so in my spare
time, one of the things
that I got into
over 20 years ago
was combat robotics, which got
started around here in the Bay
Area about 20 years ago.
And it started as
an event called
Robot Wars in Fort Mason.
And pretty early on,
one of the things that
started shaking out where the
types of designs of robots that
could be allowed, because there
were a lot of rules, mainly
a weight limit, that
you're working up against.
But the real thing that
started to come about
is like are you
building a spinner,
a lifter, a flipper, a
puncher, something that cuts?
And so the robot that we first
built back almost 20 years ago
is a robot called Rhino
where we developed
a very powerful pneumatic
kind of punching system.
And it did pretty well.
We were able to get
kind of third place.
And then there was a TV show
that was on Comedy Central
back then, now
about 12 years ago.
But when we took that same
pneumatic system, instead
of trying to leverage
off our own robot,
to turn that system
vertically, we
could actually start launching
other robots up in the air.
And so this was a much
more successful robot.
We won several championships
with this robot named Toro back
in that TV show.
And the TV show
went off the air.
And then just this
last year, ABC
called up and said they
wanted to do the show again.
And so we started building
from scratch once again.
And one of our
main things that we
started learning
about new components--
how we're going to design now
is with really high performance
components that have come out
of the automotive industry,
the electric bike industry.
Now there's actual
robot controllers
like these ones that
have a processor on board
so that you can do some
of the programming onboard
the robot as much as the
controls that you're doing.
Some things that have
really changed things
are things like battery, these
lithium polymer batteries.
The old robots we built had 40
pounds of lead acid batteries
or NiCad batteries.
Now they have six
pounds of batteries,
and they have even
better performance.
And some components we had
to fabricate ourselves.
So we actually had to design
and build our own gearboxes
in order to get the
kind of performance
to weight ratio in kind
of titanium, steel,
and aluminum gear boxes.
And the other constraint
is that you find out
that you're building this
robot, because it's TV,
two months before the TV show.
And so we went straight to
CAD working with a bunch
of the cool new Autodesk tools.
But we had to design in a
way that once we had a design
we could fabricate very fast.
So we kind of used
this flat pack
design of notching
everything together,
went to laser cut wood.
We could just hot glue
everything together,
put all our components inside
the robot, see if it works.
We probably built six or
seven versions in wood
before we went to metal.
But those exact
same cutting files
that we used in
wood we could then
put into a water jet machine.
And what we were
cutting in wood,
we're now cutting in aluminum,
titanium, very high strength
steel like AR500 steel.
And the main
constraint that you're
always up against in trying to
build a Battlebot is weight.
It's a 250-pound
weight class right now.
And so at every
stage, you're trying
to trade weight on the inside
of the robot for performance
in the weapons system or armor.
And so once you do make
it out of metal, you know,
the hot glue of the metal
world is MIG welding.
Once you now are working in
this kind of format of water jet
to MIG welding, we were
able to build bot chassis
in literally one day.
And then the much
slower part comes
when you have to cram all the
actual robotic stuff in there
and make it so that it
could perform reasonably.
Last year, the
robot that we built
was a launcher-- again,
probably three times
as powerful as any one we'd ever
built before-- called Bronco.
And it has 12,000
pounds of lifting force
in a 250-pound
robot that can exert
that force in a little less
than 1/100 of a second.
So it's a very hard robot
on itself, in a sense.
This is us fighting a
robot called Stinger.
And this was the quarter
finals of last season.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
And then in the semifinals,
we got taken out
by a robot called Tombstone
with a spinning weapon.
To give you an idea
of the kind of forces
that are involved here,
that's 3/8 aluminum
that looks like it's
torn like paper,
and armor grade 38
tie, just getting
shredded across this robot.
So being able to contain the
forces and take those forces
is really difficult.
We just finished
filming season 2.
This is the new
version of Bronco.
It has six wheels.
And basically
wheels get torn off,
so we wanted to have
a robot that that
after some of the
wheels got torn off
could still keep running.
And the new season starts
I think Thursday, June 23.
And you can see the
evolution of robot combat
as it comes together now.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Thank
you very much, Zander.
And now we're going to space
with the author of a new book
in cooperation with NASA.
Please welcome up Ariel Waldman.
[APPLAUSE]
ARIEL WALDMAN: Thanks.
Hello.
So this is an image that's from
my favorite spacecraft, Voyager
I. And if you can see that
little pale blue speck
of a pixel there,
that's actually
earth as seen from about
four billion miles away.
So that's where you can
find me if you need me.
But the reason why I love
images like these so much
is because it really shows us
how space exploration often
changes our view of ourselves
and our place in the universe.
But similarly, I
think we should change
how we view space exploration.
Most of us are just
observing astronauts
exploring on behalf of us.
But we ourselves aren't
doing much exploring.
And this relates to
my own personal story
because I was watching
a documentary called
"When We Left Earth" about
during the early days.
And I became so incredibly
inspired by this documentary
that I decided to
send someone at NASA
an email saying I was a huge
fan of what they were doing.
And if they ever
needed someone like me,
someone completely without
a science background--
I went to art school.
I was here.
Serendipitously, I got a
job at NASA from that email,
and it was a total
fan girl moment.
[APPLAUSE]
And so I wanted to
share a quick clip
from this documentary about
why I found it so inspiring.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Knew nothing about spacecraft.
We knew nothing about orbits.
-And I saw a lot of
rockets launched.
I'd say somewhere between
30% and 40% of them failed.
[EXPLOSION]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ARIEL WALDMAN: And that's
what I love so much
about this documentary,
because as they were saying,
they don't know anything
about space crafts or rockets.
They were figuring it out.
And I thought to myself,
I don't know anything
about spacecraft or rockets.
I want to work at NASA.
That sounds amazing.
So I got that chance, and it
completely changed my life.
And I got to learn about
all sorts of things--
dark matter and robots and what
our galaxy really looks like.
It looks like something
like this, actually.
And one of the coolest
things I got to learn about
were black holes.
And black holes are really
interesting because they're
these incredibly uncharted
territories of space.
They're something
that has been science
fiction for a long time, but
now they're actually science.
And they're just
fascinating, but they also
get a bit of a bad rap.
People put all their
wonders and hopes
and dreams into black holes.
They wonder all sorts of
things about, you know,
what if we live inside
of a black hole?
Or what are white holes?
Or they wonder what if we were
to fall through a black hole?
Would we actually have to spend
time with Matthew McConaughey?
I really, really hope not.
[LAUGHS]
But black holes are
incredibly evil.
They're seen as evil
things because they're
known for gobbling up planets
and stars and maybe even
entire galaxies.
And do they ever stop?
Do they ever get tired
of eating things?
Well, it turns
out, they sometimes
do get tired of eating things.
When they bite off more
than they can chew,
they actually vomit it
back out into the universe
violently in the form of
mixed up space dust and space
gas and space energy.
And that mixed up
stuff can actually
go on to create future
stars, future planets.
So in a sense, they're kind of
the creators of the universe.
And we can't image
a black hole, but we
can image a black hole's vomit,
which you can see right here.
And imaging black
vomit is really great
because it allows us to
find new black holes.
And there's actually a project
called Galaxy Zoo Radio
on spacehack.org, which
is a directory of ways
to participate in space
exploration that I had created.
And you can actually
find black holes
by combing through their vomit.
This is something that should
be science fiction, anyone being
able to discover black holes.
But it is actually science.
And turning science
fiction into science
is at the heart of NASA
innovative advanced concepts.
It's a program
that I help advise
at NASA that funds the more
sci-fi, futuristic, out there,
weird stuff that could
transform future space missions.
So the types of
stuff that they fund
are things like the
Comet Hitchhiker.
And the Comet
Hitchhiker is literally
a project where a probe can
go to a comet, tether into it,
and harvest its kinetic
energy to explore
the solar system twice as fast
as any of our current probes.
There's also projects like
the Solar Lunar Rover, which
essentially uses computer
vision to route better
routes on the moon for
rovers so that they
can stay in continuous
sunlight and actually perform
better science, and they don't
have to turn off overnight.
There's also projects like
the Titan Submarine, which
is literally a concept
to build a submarine,
send it to a moon
of Saturn, and have
it explore the lakes of
methane and ethane there and do
a bunch of cool stuff
while it's there.
Having a submarine on a moon
around Saturn is amazing to me.
And then there's projects
that are actually
about using technology from
MIT Media Lab that can actually
see behind corners, and
strapping it to a space probe,
and allowing it to actually be
able to see the inside lunar
caves, which is
really, really cool.
So the coolest thing
about NIAC is the fact
that they accept
proposals from anyone.
Anyone can apply every year
and actually submit a proposal,
get it funded, by NASA,
and actually perform
science fiction.
So to me, when it comes to space
exploration and black holes
and all of this stuff, the
thing that's really cool
is about spitting
out, vomiting out,
awesome stuff into
the universe to go on
to transform the future.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Thank you, Ariel.
And her book is entitled
"What's It Like in Space?"
It's pretty awesome.
And now to learn about
users, please welcome up
US researcher
Elizabeth Churchill.
[APPLAUSE]
ELIZABETH CHURCHILL: Hi, so I've
been studying human computer
interaction for a long time.
And more recently,
I'm turning my eye
to human data interaction.
And when I say data, I mean
all of the data about you
as a consumer that is collected
from devices and services, all
the data that you're collecting
as developers from people.
And if you take one thing
away from this talk,
I want you to just
ask yourselves, why?
Why is the data being collected?
Why are you collecting the data?
For what purpose?
Because I think
one of the things
we need as data scientists is
to be clear about the data we're
collecting.
Now, I've worked with data
scientists and designers
to build recommendation
algorithms for merchandising,
quite positive.
I'm now working with the
privacy and safety experts
to worry about some of
the concerns people have.
And the piece down the
middle is visibility.
And so even in corporations,
we don't always
have visibility into the
reasons why we collect data.
And consumers certainly don't,
and that causes anxiety.
And when you talk to people
about data collection,
they often think
about surveillance.
Now, surveillance
evokes the idea
of the collection of data
for a particular purpose.
And as we move into this new
world, though, of the internet
of things and smart
cities and smart homes,
a lot of sensor data
is being collected
with no particular
purpose in mind.
Back to the question, why?
Because we can,
just because we can,
because it might be useful
perhaps, because we haven't
thought about not doing it.
Now, data science
is in its infancy,
and it's a fetish object.
It's a fetish topic.
Everyone loves data science.
But we're at the
beginning of understanding
what we should collect and
what we're not collecting,
as well as what
we are collecting.
So it's not surprising that as
consumers and those concerned
about data, sousveillance,
or the watched
watching the watchers, is
becoming increasingly something
we're interested in.
We're asking
questions about why.
Now, I've done a
series of interviews
with people about their
concerns about data.
And it isn't black or
white, unlike my slides.
It's about wanting a
contract and a conversation.
It's about wanting
to participate,
wanting visibility.
Now, a friend of mine, when
she found out she was pregnant,
decided that she did not want to
be tracked about her pregnancy.
So she used incognito
mode for searches.
She bought nothing online.
She didn't talk on social
media about her pregnancy.
She took efforts to
opt out, including
paying for large objects like
prams with cash and gift cards
rather than credit cards.
Now, nothing wrong
with that, but what
was wrong with the
model in the data model?
It flagged her as a
potential criminal.
It flagged her as
fraudulent, potentially.
So she had to unravel that.
Data science is in its infancy,
and our predictive models
about what people's intent or
actions are not always right.
So what we're doing
if we're not careful
is creating a climate
of lack of trust.
And what that means is
people may potentially
walk away from our
services and devices
because we're not including them
in thinking hard about this.
And so again, ask why
you're collecting data.
Ask what models you're building.
Ask what data you're
not collecting in order
to build a better model,
a more rounded model.
And think about why
not participation.
Now, I mentioned to
my friend, and one
of the big issues I think
we need to think about
is meaningful opt
in and opt out.
What does it mean
to let people choose
to opt out of data collection?
In the EU, this is becoming
increasingly a big issue,
and a regulation is about to
pass, also about deletion,
the right to be forgotten.
Data science is in its infancy.
We don't yet understand how
the statistical models we buy
will cope with the
removal of data.
So deletion is a really
interesting technical problem.
I've mentioned forecasting.
Intent modeling and
forecast modeling
is clearly beneficial in
many, many, many instances.
But we have to not just
take the forecasts as given.
We have to ask why
and what, and we
have to come with the primary
premise as building trust
and collaboration with people
of whose data we're collecting.
We should start
with models of trust
first, and then think about
where we're going forward.
So I just want to
sum up the things
I've been thinking about--
asking why; meaningful opt in,
opt out.
What does it mean to delete?
What are the forecasts
models of the future?
And how can we forecast
what data we're
collecting that's artefactual?
How will it be used
and build on trust?
So I want to think
about you talking
to me about human
data interaction
from your perspective.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Well done.
Thank you, Elizabeth.
And now we're going
to find out what
happens when a nerd decides
to learn about sports.
For his walking up Toby Segaran.
TOBY SEGARAN: Hi, I'm Toby.
I really, really like gambling.
And fan fantasy
sports is actually
one of the only legal
forms of gambling
that you can do
online in the US.
And this is my story
of the 2016 NFL season.
I started noticing these
articles just appearing
on feeds and stuff like that
about how these sites were
ripping off sports fans because
there are too many sharks.
And I thought to
myself, well, maybe
I'm a shark This involves
two things I know a lot
about, gambling and algorithms,
and one thing I knew nothing
about, which was sports.
But I figured two out
of three isn't bad,
and maybe I should
give this a shot.
So I'll talk you through
how fantasy football works.
You can see you
come to these sites,
and there are lots
of competitions.
There are different buy-ins,
different prizes you can get.
And then you can click through
to one of the actual contests
and you can see that there
are different payouts.
Most notably is that
500 people can enter,
but only 100 people win here.
And some of the top prizes
are actually quite high.
You're only paying $27, and
you could win over $1,000.
And to actually
set up the teams,
you buy a bunch of real life
players, and you have a budget.
So you can't just pick
all the best ones.
And you get points
based on how well
they play in the Sunday games.
So this is how you
set up the teams.
And this is everything
I knew about football
before I started.
[LAUGHS] Matt Saracen
and Moxon, they
were the main guy, the ones
that make the movies about it.
So there's a quarterback.
And it turns out there
are other players too.
This is Antonio Brown.
He's a wide receiver.
This is the guy the
quarterback throws to.
And this will become
important later.
They can get you a lot of
fantasy points as well.
It also turns out there's
an entire other team called
the defense.
And the defense plays
when the quarterbacks
playing on the other team.
So the quarterbacks
never even played
each other, which is, I guess,
why the movies are always
plotted around one quarterback
and not so much a rivalry.
OK, so here's why
this is difficult.
When you construct a team, there
are always different choices.
And basically there are three
quadrillion possible teams
once you figure out all
the combinations of players
you could put in.
So that's far too
many for a human
to consider and even far too
many for a machine to consider.
The strategy also is that
you have to basically play
really risky teams.
Because being just slightly
above average doesn't get you
any prizes in these
tournament contests.
They have different ones,
but that's less fun.
And I figured this would
be the way to play.
So what I figured
out was I needed
to enter many teams
per week, figuring out
the best players, what
the scores would likely
to be, and construct
a team out of those,
and then actually construct
a portfolio of teams
that have a chance of
being right near the top.
So I did a bunch of
modeling, but it turns out
that if you just
average the projected
scores that the
sports sites give you,
those are actually a fairly
good proxy for how well
the players are going to do.
But what's interesting
is that even though this
might be the average
score that they get,
the distributions of the
scores are quite different.
The quarterback is
much more consistent
than the wide receiver.
So in order to have these high
variance teams, these really
risky teams, you want to
think about the distributions
that you're playing with.
The other thing is that the
players' scores correlate
with each other.
Because the quarterback
passes to the wide receiver,
they actually have
high correlations
between their scores.
Essentially, if the
quarterback does well,
the wide receiver
tends to do well.
So having two on the same
team-- these two players
from the same real life team--
helps increase your variance.
So the idea would be to
create a set of teams
with really high variance
who are going to score really
well or really poorly and
that have low correlation
with each other.
And of course you still
want them to score well.
And so the way I did this
was I created a set of teams
at random and then
sort of predict
the outcomes of this portfolio
based on probabilities of what
those score, given
the distributions,
given their correlations
with each other.
So you can see here that I
can calculate the probability
that one of my teams will score
above 140, the probability
that one will score
above 160-- 160
was a good metric for being
in that top green spot--
and the correlations
between them.
And then we optimize by
changing out the players.
And maybe you can increase
the expected values
and the variance of
each team while also
decreasing the correlation.
We just keep doing
this randomly,
and we can see the probability's
getting higher and higher.
So here are my final results.
For the 2015 season,
expectation is negative 10%
because they take a cut.
My rate of return was 296%,
but only eight of my teams
actually won.
Yep.
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: So
how many people
here have read "Programming
Collective Intelligence"?
Really?
Nobody?
Best selling data science book?
Anyway, that's what happens
when the author decides
to learn how to play football.
Now we have a Double E star.
Please welcome up Star Simpson.
[APPLAUSE]
STAR SIMPSON: So I got into
electronics almost completely
by accident.
And thank you, Brady.
My name's Star Simpson, and
I'm a hardware designer.
I got into electronics when
I was 14 years old because I
found this book.
And I found this book
in this old computer lab
at my high school that
had been abandoned.
It was locked most of the time.
For some reason I was in
it, and I found a book.
And it was so important to me
I knew I needed to have it.
So I promised I was going to
take it home for the summer
without asking.
I took it home, and I
looked at all the parts
I needed to build every project
in it and went to my mom.
And I was like, Mom, I
need all these electronics.
And it was a lot of
money, but she did it.
And she ended up getting
me all the parts.
I spent the whole summer
building every project in it.
And I realize now she got a
bargain, honestly, entertaining
me for three whole months.
And I went, and I finished
every project in that book,
cover to cover.
I left no project unbuilt,
one after another.
It was amazing.
I learned so much.
I built all of these things.
I built a circuit that had
a game where you touch it,
and like you won or lost.
I built something that
lets you count numbers
on a little digital display.
I mean, I thought
it was really cool.
I built something
that remembered
which state it should be in.
And I felt like I
gained this super power.
It was awesome.
That's me gaining a super power.
I had shorter hair then.
The thing that I
thought was so cool
about it was that you learned
to connect things that are,
you know, math, to
how it's described,
to how it exists in
the physical world.
And the thing that's
great to me especially
is I'm not the only one to
have had that experience.
Millions of people have actually
used this same book to learn,
and I know engineers
today who still
think in terms of the pictures
that were in the book.
I ended up going back to
school, my high school.
I joined the robotics team.
I ended up becoming
president of it.
I got into MIT.
I ended up studying
electrical engineering,
getting a job as an
electrical engineer,
and I think it's amazing
what a little nudge can do.
But I think today's world
is different than the one I
learned in.
So this is all of the Radio
Shacks that are now closed.
It's basically a map
of the United States.
Fortunately, we
have the internet.
That's fantastic, right?
But I think there's something
to the physical experience
of building electronics
that's different.
It's tangible.
When you poke at something,
and you can debug it,
and you can see where
your mistake is,
that's so, so
important, so tangible.
So I found that book again.
It's called "Getting
Started in Electronics."
And, you know, the whole
thing is drawn by hand.
The idea is that you
found someone's notebook,
and it just happens to be
about learning electronics.
I forgot about it for years,
and I just found it again.
I put it back, by the way,
at the end of the summer.
And it talks you through how
to understand electronics
as a language.
So let me talk a little
bit about how that works.
Electronics are described
in terms of these pictures.
So this is sort of like the
floor plan of a circuit.
So each of those is
a meaningful symbol.
It's part of it.
So once you have
that floor plan,
you can understand
how it works, and you
can figure out how to build
the physical thing from it.
So in that sense to me, it's a
lot like learning how to read
and learning how the physical
arrangement of things
is meaningful.
So once you can understand a
schematic, which the book works
you through, you can go on to
build the physical hardware
based on it.
Or you can even go in reverse.
And this was a major
insight for me,
was learning you could
look at a piece of hardware
and work out how
it goes together.
In fact, this is a picture
to me of an insight that
took a lot of time to build up.
This was a thing
you do, is you could
hold the piece of
hardware up to a light.
And you could see how
everything was connected.
And if you're
really patient, you
can write down all
of the connections
and understand how it works.
But so, you know, schematics
are usually these symbols.
They're usually the
same sort of components.
You see them everywhere.
And once you can figure out
how they all go together,
you can decide what
you want them to do.
And I started thinking
about how to make
the piece of hardware that
included all of those insights.
So you can see here, instead
of holding it up to a light,
I've designed a circuit
board that shows
how everything's connected.
It has the schematic.
It includes the language
that describes itself.
This is the backside
of the same board.
You can see a
description telling you
how it's supposed to work
and what it's supposed to do.
Because I want everyone to be
able to have the experience
I did when I was first
learning electronics,
to fill the gap left
behind by Radio Shack.
They are called
Circuit Classics.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST:
And as it happens,
you can back her on
Kickstarter right now.
But Google asked
for at least one
practical talk, so we're
going to-- [LAUGHS]
So we're going to learn
how various haircuts apply
to product design.
Please welcome up Nadav.
[APPLAUSE]
NADAV AHARONY: So whenever
you design a new product,
especially if it's
disruptive, you're
going to run into a
lot of limitations--
technology, problems,
bugs, delays,
missing data, or missing users.
Now, the more value you have,
the more problems your users
will let you get away with.
The issue is that if
you have design problems
in their experience, they'll
abandon you before they
figure out your value.
So that's where the
mullet comes in.
For those of you who haven't
been around in the 80s,
or certain parts
of the US today,
a mullet is a haircut that
offers business up front
and a party in the back.
The mullet approach
to product design
offers you delighting
the users up front
while keeping all of your
limitations in the back.
We'll talk about a
few examples and ways
to try to approach this.
So one of the most basic
things you start with
is use what you have, for those
of you who remember MacGyver.
And basically a very
common set of problems
are related to delays and
network connectivity issues.
So by anticipating them,
and being proactive,
you can actually cache
and preload things
so that when your user
gets to the point,
they see an
instantaneous content
and feel like it's very fast.
That's one of the basic things.
Instagram is great at
these kinds of tricks.
And another trick they have
is an optimistic UI, where
when the user presses an
action, the UI tells them
it's also already successful
even before they synced it
to the server, being
optimistic about it.
Another totally different way
to look at your limitations
is to just treat them as part
of your product requirements.
I was working a few years
ago on a fitness experience
when people didn't
have data plans yet.
So we actually
designed an experience
the showed the UI
every three days
and assumed that within three
days, they'll connect to Wi-Fi
and will upload stuff
in the background.
We also were trying to
do accurate retroactivity
recognition, which
didn't work well
with those phones of
those days with lots
of bugs, battery issues.
It was hard to get
the users to hold
the phone in the right way
for us to accurately get it.
So what we ended up doing
is a high level score
of your activity level
that was very easy
to score, very easy to collect,
and not killing the battery.
And the users could have
the phone anywhere, even
in their backpack.
We could still tell if you're
walking more than taking
the elevator or things
like this, which
was great for our experience.
Still with fitness,
another type of limitation
can actually come
from the outside world
and the environment where
your product lives, you know,
like winter.
So winter offers you limitations
in weather, shorter days,
and lots of heavy family meals.
So when you go out running
after that heavy family
meal in January, you're
going to be very far
away from your record
in the summer, which
will be demotivating.
Strava caught onto the fact
that the Gregorian calendar
is really nicely aligned
with that dip in fitness.
So by resetting your
personal annual score,
your first run is
already a record,
and your second run is a better
improvement on that record.
So they're using the
limitations and the solutions
from the environment.
Have you ever thought about
why Google Cardboard doesn't
have a headband?
So Cardboard tries to
run on as many phones
as possible with lots of
processing power and graphics
abilities.
You should also know that with
VR, if things are jittery,
people get motion sickness.
By not having a strap,
they're forcing the user
to hold it with both
hands and move slower
in the speed of their torso
or their shoulders which
is much slower than the
speed of your head moving.
So by using one limitation,
you solve a worst one.
Form informs the function.
Now, a totally
different approach
is to get your users to help.
If you design your
experience carefully enough,
you can have your
users do your chores
and enjoy them and solve
all your limitations
as you progress.
A common problem is
getting to critical mass.
And a common solution is
finding value for a single user
like Delicious did
where users started
by going into saving their
own bookmarks in Delicious.
And over time, the value grew
and the network effect kicked.
So like hair, your
product grows with time.
Remember this.
You can take this
approach and even do
a totally different
experience for early adopters.
Waze had a data problem,
a data limitation,
where they didn't have enough
roads in the beginning.
So they had a
game-like experience
where their first users
were driving through roads
like a Pac-Man and eating up
power ups on new roads, which
motivated them to
help map the system.
Once that was done, they
threw away that experience.
You can even take that
solution and productize it.
Luis Von Ahn has been
great about taking
these very hard problems and
making fun user experiences.
While they learn a new
language or play a game,
they're actually
solving hard problems
like translating the internet
or tagging photos and images.
As you see, the mullet
is a very powerful tool.
And we have to treat
it respectfully.
We have to remember
that our goal is
to delight users
not to scam them
and not to make
ourselves look better.
And some companies
tend to forget that.
A few examples, you
know, Ashley Madison
had a female number problem,
and so they used bots and fake
accounts to try to solve that.
Volkswagen had a
technology problem,
and their workaround was to find
a detector for being tested.
And they are still
screwing their users.
So don't screw your users.
Some other takeaways
are that you really have
to understand your limitations.
You have to understand your
users and your motivation.
And you have to understand
the milieu, the environment
in which your product
lives in, in order
to design the best
product experience, which
is not necessarily always the
best engineering experience.
Now, as you see, this
is a very powerful tool.
It could be applied
to other domains
as well like giving talks.
When you need to give a talk
about a topic you have no idea
about, pick the right experience
that you'll still get applause
at the end like 20 slides,
5 minutes, and no audience
questions at the end.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: I
never thought it
would be awesome to be
compared to a mullet.
Thank you, Nadav.
And now our final
talk is just going
to give you some food
for thought for when you
do design those applications.
Please welcome up Renee DiResta.
[APPLAUSE]
RENEE DIRESTA: So
conspiracy theorists
think that the Brazilian
government, the CDC,
and the World
Health Organization
are lying to us
about the Zika Virus.
But they're not sure whether
to blame vaccines, GMOs,
chemtrails, or Monsanto.
And residents in Portland,
Oregon, a few years back,
voted to eliminate fluoride
from their water supply.
And depending on
which side you asked,
it was either a
toxic chemical that
caused cancer or a
toxic mind controlled
substance used by fascist
regimes-- and also dentists.
And then there was
the time last year
when the federal
government invaded Texas.
Now, that actually
never happened,
but local residents
were so convinced
that routine military practice
exercise Jade Helm was an Obama
attempt to impose martial law
that the governor of the state
said that he would have the
state national guard monitor
the exercise.
So, we laugh at
this stuff, and we
say these conspiracy
theorists, they're
so unlike the rest of us.
But this is actually happening
with increasing frequency.
And so we need to
understand why.
Because the thing that
these stories have in
common is that all of these
myths and conspiracies
propagated on social networks.
Algorithms are
influencing policy and not
necessarily for the better.
I'm sure everyone in here has
heard of the filter bubble.
It's the idea that
platforms, they
want to show you
what you want to see
because it keeps you engaged
and targetable for longer.
And the filter bubble was
about partisan politics,
but what we're seeing now
is recommendation engines.
And it's a little bit
more like radicalization.
Because once you join one
conspiracy theory group
on Facebook,
anti-vax, for example,
it starts to serve you content
not only about that conspiracy
but about related conspiracies.
You probably want to know
about chemtrails, about GMOs,
about how the earth is flat.
And yes, that's real.
And once you join
those groups, people
will tell you-- they
will welcome you.
And they'll reinforce
your beliefs.
And they'll congratulate
you on being awake.
And the experience is very
much like being recruited
into a cult. Because social
networking has disrupted
the market for cult leaders.
And the reason this
matters is that we're
at a point where
over 50% of adults
say that they get their news
primarily from social channels
like Facebook.
And it matters what you see,
because if you see things
from people you know or
people in your groups,
you're more likely to trust it.
And the other kind
of corollary here
is that social networking also
made us all content creators.
But it really deprecated
the editorial function.
So now we have a point where
anyone can write anything
anywhere, and as long as they
can achieve enough uptake,
it's likely to rise in search
rankings on social networks.
So we've reached a
point where things
that are popular and
emotionally resonant
are much more likely to
be seen by you than things
that are true.
Facts really just don't matter.
So the power to influence our
opinions, the power to shape
believes, increasingly
lies with those
who most effectively
disseminate their message,
whether that message
is true or not.
And what happens online
and what happens offline,
there's no difference there.
There's no gap there.
This is, in some
ways, fantastic.
Social networks are a
great tool for organizing.
But the problem that we have is
that in conspiracy theory land,
there's an asymmetry of passion.
It's actually a very
small number of people,
but they're producing far
more content than what
you would see from
the people who aren't
really prone to those beliefs.
And we saw this play out
in an interesting way
in California last year
during the heated debate
about the vaccine law, which
was that the conspiracy
that vaccines cause
Autism eventually
lead us to a measles outbreak
because school vaccination
rates were so low.
And so legislators
stepped up and tried
to remedy the problem
legislatively.
And all of a sudden,
the asymmetry of passion
was in full view.
Because the vast
majority of content
across all social channels--
Pinterest, Facebook, Twitter,
you name-- was anti-vax.
But when legislators actually
reached out and started
polling their constituents
and reaching out
to people directly,
they found that over 67%
were in favor of the law, and
over 85% believed that vaccines
were safe and didn't buy into
the conspiracy theory nonsense.
But those people aren't
getting up in the morning
to tweet about this.
People aren't getting
up in the morning
to tweet about the
earth being round.
And so we've reached
the point where
the kind of
legislative interaction
spawned by conspiracy
theory groups waste time,
and they waste money.
And so now it's
up to us in tech,
which is why I'm
giving this talk here,
to start thinking about the
ethics of platform design
and how our
recommendation engines
and sort of the
unintentional side effects
are actually shaping the future.
So Facebook has been in
the news about this a lot
over the last week.
And they are using
humans in addition
to algorithms to kind of amplify
certain editorial stories.
They are starting
to note things that
are hoaxes on the platform.
You know, and here
we are Google,
and Google was talking about
maybe having a truth ranking.
But I'm going to close with
a paraphrase from the filter
bubble.
We need these algorithms to have
a sense of civic responsibility
in order for the web to be
that thing that we've all
dreamed of it being.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: All right,
thank you very much.
We'll be back next year.
And the videos
will be up shortly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]